Ted Cruz getting an unexpected welcome
at the airport the Texas senator
surrounded by a group of angry
immigration protesters they slammed him
for conditions at the border watch this
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
senator Cruz appeared unfazed by the
confrontation even stopping to take a
picture with the fans in the middle of
the chaos Dana how would you handle this
well probably not as graciously as he
did and Ted Cruz actually has great
sense of humor is pretty funny and so as
well I think these this type of thing
either one it turns people off from
running for office or two it annoys
everybody that's in the airport three
there the fact that he is unfazed shows
that he you have to have a level as a
conservative of somebody who can just
sort of deal with it not overreact
because imagine if he had that would be
the video that would be everywhere I
thought he handled it right I'm just sad
it happened to him Katie but isn't it
like First Amendment free speech he's a
public he elected public official people
should speak to him okay
not at airports one you might be looking
for a Cinnabon exactly yeah if you're
gonna get between people there's
Cinnabon and their coffee at 5:00 and I
don't know what time this was but any
time in the airport actually especially
if you're trying to get on the road and
catch your flight it's not a good idea
probably but this kind of thing is not
effective you know my court they're
chanting let the children free the
children where are you gonna put the
children I mean a lot of the times these
children are sent by themselves alone
unaccompanied they've been taken away
from sex traffickers they have been
prevented from being sent to trap sex
traffickers in America they're actually
in a safer position in DHS or HHS
custody than they are just getting
thrown out to whoever so this is not
only an effective but their solution to
just throw out the kids from custody is
not a good one either Jesse but I think
if we just look at the substance of the
matter I think lots of people are upset
about separating children from parents
and
his parents and you know so the question
is you know should the Senate should our
politicians be doing something different
yeah like passing laws to fix the border
yeah that's the Republicans have been
saying for about a year and the
Democrats have done nothing here's the
deal I was on the subway the other day
and some guy takes his phone and there
was a picture of a dead migrant baby
face down in the Rio Grande and he
shoves it in my face and he goes don't
you care about this of course I care I'm
sorry I did that this is emotional
blackmail of what the left does they put
something out there and they say you
don't care about kids and you support
death but if you look at what the
Republicans have offered laws lines
borders those are the things that save
lives
those are compassionate ideas and those
are the kind of things that get
everybody's security and safety on both
sides of the border these protesters
they don't know anything about the
Flores agreement or the fact that Obama
built the very detention facilities that
they're calling a concentration camps or
the fact that Democrats didn't do
anything for six months while
Republicans were asking for money to
help this they don't care about the
traffickers or the fact that the the
migrants stream goes this way and then
the narcotics smugglers go the other way
while Border Patrol's destructive they
don't know anything about that they just
want to chant and get in your face huh
maybe the Republicans have power for all
power for two years maybe they don't
care I think we both care wants to fix I
think people want borders with some
compassion not all 22 another rule about
what's going on no separating children
from parents is you don't know if
they're actually their parent while they
can we track you know what we agree on
we agree that you actually think that
you should just keep a trafficked kid
with an adult with no idea I think you
think that's a good idea you can do what
the issue
we put in place by this president to in
fact try to discourage families from
seeking asylum your side supports human
trafficking you can support that you
know that's the kind of heated truth
this leads us nowhere
yes that is the physical embodiment of
Twitter right because I don't think
those people care about the children
it's just a football for their team
sport or else they would have said
something years ago but this is the
football now that they can use to score
against Ted Cruz oh I am I'm it's like
you know they're not flying anywhere
alright that bothers me I mean it's like
of course free speech love it but no the
airport is sacred my man you can't go in
there
I'm tricky Oh people aren't their worst
selves at the airport and they're the
worst selves at protest put him together
I remember Andrew Andrew Breitbart did
something very funny he was at an event
that attracted left-wing protesters what
did he do remember this lady
rollerbladed over to them and invited
him to breakfast at Applebee's yes that
was it that's what we need more of we
need more tables these protesters made
Ted Cruz and a sympathetic figure yes
which is not easy you can't get in there
unless you are going somewhere where
what's that what's that I think a
baggage I know it was look at the gate
where are they going